okay just don't get out of the way
um folks uh big crowd up here tonight
and big crowd out there in the audience
welcome to upstairs of book hampton um
it's a tremendous pleasure to welcome
tom wolf who will be introducing mr
whites
mr wolf is an author of many many books
including most recently the audiobook
ambush at fort bragg and please join me
now in welcoming
tom wolf
i'm delighted to see so many white soul
files out tonight
i couldn't find a parking place in the
parking lot around the corner i wondered
why and
it now i know this is great this is
absolutely great
like many of you i until 1992 i really
thought
i knew all there was necessary to know
about john white's career
of course i had known him as a one of
the most brilliant designers in america
he had
been a racing car driver he had
written several marvelous novels
including
friends in high places which became
quite a cult book among german
intellectuals particularly younger
german intellectuals because there was a
portrait of a
um a very decent
nice man who became a nazi brown shirt
and i think this really struck a chord
in
uh the new generation in in germany and
of course also i knew
john as the man who had his tag on the
back of more metropolitan transit
authority buses
than the most active uh graffiti artist
in all of new york
um but as i say in 1992 i suddenly saw
an entirely new side of
john's life he became a biographer
and he wrote hitless diplomat
which was which is a biography of uh
joachim i know how to pronounce that
joac like that yeah
joakim found ribbon-trop of course was
hitler's foreign foreign minister
at that time i figured that i had there
was really nothing more to be said about
the nazi era nothing else to be learned
until i read hitler's diplomat which
whose not only was the striking uh
personal story
of one of the two men who did not belong
with the nazis
von ribentrop but also it brought alive
there's nothing else i've ever read
about that entire era the social media
uh in which nazism
rose uh and the the strange battle of
classes that went on
went on in the 20s and 30s in in
in germany and hitler's banker the book
that john has just
published is an even more brilliant
portrait
of of that era and of the second man who
did not belong
um within the nazi uh
uh in in in the nazi movement uh
house give me that first name again
jalmar
it's a norwegian name right so danish
name
um horace really shocked
uh the the banker who
in fact was not born as an aristocrat
but one of the most aristocratic
men of most aristocratic bearing who
probably ever lived in
uh in in europe and was really
as john wrote these two books that i for
the first time well i thought i knew
john pretty well
learned about his you the background
that really qualifies him absolutely
uniquely
to write about uh people like von
ribentrop
and uh shocked john was really born into
a family that was very much
a part of social berlin
in the 20s uh and and the 30s
it was the time of the cabaret in
christopher isherwood's wonderful term
in which
social climbing and social life took on
a very much a loose
aggressively bohemian aggressively
decadent
atmosphere john's father who was
robert solomon whites who was known as
bobby whites
because english english slang
english and things english curiously
enough in in germany in the 1920s
uh was extremely chic and so
and and bobby weitz was
the chicest of the sheik if anything
because he had been
a uh decorated with iron cross for valor
in the first
world war he was wealthy a wealthy
manufacturer he was extremely
good-looking
had a beautiful wife hedy john's uh
mother
they in the winter they went every place
you should go in the windows emirates in
the summer they went to
lake como and san remo and all the other
great resorts they lived in the
equivalent of the east
60s in manhattan and uh and had
had the hamptons done ten times over in
the places they went in the uh
in the uh uh in in the summertime
and john was sent off to boarding school
in saint paul's in england
again the the chic quality of things
british
uh in the in the cabaret period in in in
german life
uh and uh three of the three of the
outstanding
alumni of saint paul's are john milton
uh samuel peeps and john weitz
uh so it's a very venerable british a
very vulnerable british
institution uh and
even when the nazis came to power
john's father and i don't think i'm
telling any family secrets here
could not simply could not believe
that hitler was serious in his
anti-jewish
campaign even though he had made his
views very clear in mineconf
uh it just seemed unbelievable because
at that time
in berlin the gap
or the between
jews and non-jews was much smaller than
in new york at that time
uh there were actually comparatively a
handful
of jews in berlin at that particular
time
and it was a tremendous psychological
shock as well as a shock in
every other possible way to uh to john's
father bobby white
that in fact this campaign was
serious with a terrible vengeance and he
did not leave
germany until
august of 1938 two months before it was
would have been impossible for any
jew to leave to leave
germany
john exactly i think a rather
beautiful form of revenge uh
as a young man uh early in
20 years old he entered the the american
oss office of strategic services the
forerunner of the cia
and participated in probably what was
the most dangerous
espionage mission of the second world
war
going behind german lines posing as a
german officer
to establish ties with the german
resistance resistance movement
and i can see the
the fascination that
john has had with these these two
remarkable uh men
von ribentrop who was
uh reverend trump was a club man
essentially it was
his going with hitler was as if somebody
from the maidstone
club uh had turned up at the elbow of
abby hoffman in chicago
in the in 1968 and in fact much more
unbelievable
than that and shocked the
supremely self-confident extremely
talented
uh banker also simply did not belong and
would never call hitler mine furo
uh in his mind he was simply well i'm
taking
the book tells it better than i possibly
possibly can
to me that that is the uh that
background
uh simply heightens the tremendous
excitement
of john's work as a biographer
and so i now will turn you
over to the astounding man himself
john
easy as white's fashion designer to be
out trumped by tom
sartorially i'm so grateful to all of
you for coming out in this
misery it shows how many people are
willing to rush out
and listen to tom wolf
even the great jim brady who stands over
there your own journalist
anyway i'm going to do a little reading
from this
book the the um
the business of hitler which course
intrigues all of us i i think
um woody allen had it right he said
for a long time he didn't know that
hitler was a nazi
he thought he was a fellow who worked in
the telephone company
which is very much his way other ways
are
don't worry the reading will only be 80
or 90 minutes
this is the introduction to this book
short the time of adolf hitler continues
to fascinate
and to horrify the events he unleashed
baffle and bewilder even those of us who
lived in the midst of them
how could they have happened in germany
that bastion of
ethic logic and enlightenment with its
high rate of literacy
and education even though some were well
born most of hitler's paladins began as
vagabonds
and failures their worship of national
socialism and its high priest was
comparatively easy to explain
but what of those with secure
backgrounds and worldly success who
decided to throw in their lot with
hitler
what could persuade a prominent
industrialist
landowner banker lawyer physician or
academic
to join a mixture of vulgar
working-class brawlers
and hate-filled upper-class misfits
the internationally famous german banker
horace greeley was one of the anomalies
his place at hitler's side seemed so
incongruous
uh in fact as in congress as his melange
of names
shah's early endorsement and six
subsequent
know how legitimized
eventually helped him fulfill his many
promises to the german
people in fact aside without chart
hitler would not have lasted a year
the seasoned banker first became world
famous in 1923
as the democratic rights tough new
currency commissioner
he throttled the fledgling republic's
ruinous runaway inflation
restored a semblance of financial order
and probably saved his nation
from anarchy that same year adolf hitler
an
upstart agitator and political loudmouth
tried to overthrow the government
bavaria as a first step toward national
revolution
he landed in jail ten years
later adolf hitler now the nazi
chancellor of germany
recruited the famous into the newly
structured
nazi hierarchy this
is story
now for the introductory chapter
the thing that leads into this story
i'll explain his names later 69
a tall forbidding gray-haired figure
dressed in a rumpled business suit
his reptilian neck rising from an
incongruously informal sports shirt
worn with a tie stood on a small
platform
in nuremberg's palace of justice
he was flanked by a white-helmeted
american military policeman
they faced a vast courtroom crowded with
people
for a year day after day he had shared
the duck just below the platform with
21 other men all defendants
all accused of war crimes his assigned
seat
was at the far right of the front row
facing the dock their defense attorney
sat just below them photographs of the
fallen and disheveled
nazi deities of the nazi
firmament crowded onto two long wooden
benches like
superannuated school boys had appeared
in magazines and newspapers all over the
world
shocked one of the world's most famous
bankers
germany's senior representative during
two decades
of international conferences the nazis
former minister of economics
and president of the rice bank which was
the
german equivalent of the federal reserve
bank
and member of hitler's cabinet calmly
faced the judges
and their decision the verdict was
pronounced by the dapper
former attorney general of the united
states
francis biddle the american member of
the international
military tribunal speaking in english
biddle said that the accused
was acquitted of the charges against
them he was free
through shaq's earphones a tiny
mechanical voice
needlessly and redundantly repeated the
chord's sentence in german
who spoke excellent english had no need
for interpreters
his hawk nose leathery face showed
neither relief
nor joy he almost shrugged the shoulders
as if regretting the waste of time the
courts
as well as his own like the easy winner
of a drawing room debate he accepted the
verdict
as a foregone conclusion for him
there had never been one moment of doubt
he knew that he would be acquitted nor
did he feel a single second of guilt
the harsh testimony and brutal evidence
about the mass murder
of civilians and military prisoners and
the horrifying films from the freed
extermination camps
had crushed many of his fellow accused
that he knew the judges would find him
innocent of any complicity with this
beastliness
as for quote conspiracy to prepare for
war
unquote and quote conspiracy to commit
war unquote the crimes with which he was
charged
he had indeed helped rebuild germany's
military strength
but for the sake of peace not for the
conduct of war
if he had heard it was on the side of
patriotism
like most of the world he too had been
deceived and betrayed by adolf hitler
and he had even been sent to dachau
surely the verdict proved that he had
been
what he had been claiming all along he
made a small curtis bow
and left the platform the ten men
who had stood to hear their sentence
before him earlier that day
were no longer in the courtroom they had
all been sentenced to hang
the next morning that is how the story
begins
the statements about patriotism are
his view of things as the book unfolds i
think you'll find
that there might be some doubts
and for that i'll read you the last
chapter of the book i had now worked on
this book for over two and a half years
and as usual i had become terribly
acquainted with my subject
with him with this strange man
with this dreadful mixture of things
with this participant in the awful
days and times
i'd watched him rise i'd watch them fall
but i had never met him i do know that
he was not just a banker he was a man of
wit
a man of great charm occasionally a man
who
married two most attractive and most
interesting women one of whom
he had to split up with because she
became a nazi and he didn't
the other one very young who married him
when he was
in bad trouble with the nazis
nevertheless she said
that doesn't matter we'll get along
i was about to put the book to bed
and my publisher was ready for it when i
was on the phone to a
journalist in munich an old friend who
had in the past done me some favors
a woman of great reputation and great
journalistic strength and i said to her
while we were gabbing i said just for
the heck of it do me a favor
look into the munich phone book said
i've got it right here
said will you look up if there's
somebody called shacht
and which one and she said you mean the
old
yes so she said you know
there's a nancy here i said that's
his last wife his widow an extremely
beautiful girl he married when he was 25
years older than she
and who stuck with them through thick
and thin and they even had two children
so i said do me a favor find out if you
can make a
date with her i'd love to meet her come
to her apartment
ten minutes later i got a call saying
she'd be delighted to see you
well off i was on a plane to munich
i'd heard that she was fond of things
pink
so i sent ahead some pink roses and the
next thing i knew
well here we go i still had 30 minutes
until my rendezvous with a 90 year old
nancy schacht i wanted some time to
think before i
faced her in the shacht apartment
i found a small kunditorai a coffee shop
around the corner it served magnificent
bavarian pastries
and strong coffee the place was quite
empty except for an elderly well-dressed
couple obviously
at their stamfish their usual table
they spoke in the slightly nasal accent
of the north
and were most churches to the young girl
who served them their
coffee and cake noblesse oblige
they were sure to know manciacht this
residential section of munich across the
isar river
from the main part of town is home to
many wealthy
retirees they all know one another
coincidentally at the end of the war a
group of us all american military
intelligence people
had a villa nearby enough stalling
soon i would ring the bell marked dr
schaft
and then i would have to ask questions i
tried to assemble the list
when you write biography you put the
facts into chronological order
and then place them into context with
the events
of the time you also try to reconstruct
the way people
thought not easy that in recent history
seems hard to swallow it is hard to
believe that 40
short years ago u.s senator joseph
mccarthy caused decent americans to
compromise their principles
by making other americans into outcasts
because they refused to think the way
you were supposed to
mccarthy was a hero to many okay
the questions i would ask about his
admitted prejudices
or would i i could never accept shah's
view of the jews
nor could my father and insistence
on designating christianity as the only
cultural basis
for german and probably european culture
would have robbed us
of so much great painting theater music
architecture and literature
no sense than asking the question it
would never be understood
shah's view of democracy was also flawed
that so was the american version until
women's suffrage and civil rights
legislation
what about his towering ambition he
freely admitted it
and considered a laudable trait
he was born into an educated environment
that was haunted
by a constant lack of money as a child
he could probably be forgiven for
swearing that it would never happen to
him
also did he want to provide excuse me
did he want to prove himself
equal to his mother's titled family
was he trying to remove the taint of a
mezayas
of his father's all understandable
but his youthful ambition became a
lifelong
obsession the germans have a word for it
gilton's the need
to be recognized he would do anything
for recognition he was even curious when
his achievements
were not listed by a nazi newspaper he
detested
was he a genius he made his
international reputation in 1923
by insisting on dictatorial powers to
deal with
runaway inflation a national emergency
how he became a currency commissioner is
still an open question
some feel that it was his partner's way
of reading himself
of shaq while creating a powerful
government contact
it was his partner who persuaded the
government
to hire shaft was he inventive
no doubt behind the razzle dazzle you
remained a deeply conservative banker
who believed in the gold standard an
export
in profit and then solid collateral
his impoverished beginnings his time as
a journalist
and as a lobbyist taught him that if you
do not
own a suit of tales you have to borrow
one
what matter of illusion is the basis for
a deal so long as the deal
succeeds what of his patriotism
it became his justification for almost
all his personal and public decisions
and he based his nuremberg defense on it
in the kaisers germany patriotism was
usually proven in blood
on the field of battle the chart never
wore
a uniform his high color was his battle
armor
but he was never part of the parade
ground fraternity
did he decide he would show them
it took more than a uniform to serve
your country
patriotism became his obsession
international financial imaginations
battles with foreign statesman's
fights with the weimar democratic german
leaders
his early support of hitler his breach
with hitler
whatever he did was done for his
personal definition
of patriotism was he guilty of helping
hitler haunt the world
he was freed by the international
military tribunal at nuremberg by
defending himself
against the narrowest of accusations
the tribunal's credibility depended on
the validity
the enforceability of its indictments
they could not prosecute a man for
loving the devil they could only accuse
him of helping the devil to do a
specific
criminal thing the real crime of course
unprosecuted was admiring him
was he ever a nazi there was a time when
he admired hitler surely
he had to have known from the very
beginning that hitler stood for
murder brutality and arrogance the
viciousness of the original nazi program
the earliest demonstrations of brutality
the rome affair that was the murder of
the heads
of the stormtroopers in 1934
the murder of the functions a former
chancellor of germany and other
conservatives
the open street beatings and the
arbitrary arrests
could have left him no doubt he even
voiced his complaints directly to hitler
as early as 1934
he knew he was dealing with a thug and
his henchman
he made sure never to join the party he
detested war
and extra legal excesses like crystal
night
because they interfered with
international commerce
he loved trade anywhere everywhere
anytime and with anyone it was his
language his music as religion
hitler's anti-semitism interfered with
trade hitler's military buildup after
the necessary rearmament
interfered with trade autarky
the business of a country being
independent
and guring who ran the german economy at
the end of the war interfered
with trade as did gobbles
and his propaganda helped some jews
because their persecution might have
caused international boycotts
he tried to block hitler's demands on
the rice bank
because his war preparations were
inflationary and ruined exports
eventually he broke with hitler but he
had also broken with a monarchist
and with the democrats he simply could
not believe
that any german government was smart
enough clever enough
worldly enough to run the country in his
view
one only international commerce backed
by military might
could keep germany great and it seemed
eminently clear that only he alma horus
gridisha
understood that formula even after he
was dismissed he could not bear to think
that the man and the chancellor
would be so foolish as to ignore the
views of his wisest minister
would i ask her any of these questions
never besides now i think i know the
answers
so i paid for my coffee and my cooking
and left the nice little coffee place
and its seductive smells
on the way out the old couple silently
gestured to curtis's greeting
a few minutes later i rang the bell
marked dr
mansi shah was still tall beautiful
gracious
and filled with charm she had brewed
excellent tea and served delicious
pastries
we chatted a while at random and then i
asked her a few details about their
travels their homes their children and
the circumstances
of a husband's death it was easy to see
why xiaoma had fallen in love with her
and that's all
now that that that leaves an awful lot
of open questions
and and for a little while and until the
questions get too tough
i'm at your disposal are there any
questions
the first meeting between hitler came
about when
had already broken with the democratic
regime of germany and didn't quite know
what to do he was floating free trying
to make up his mind on
what was happening and a famous banker
who was on the board
of the rice bunk with him earlier
introduced them and cha said well i'll
find out what this is all about
i know they're thugs but there are some
ideas that are worth learning
that's how it came about it was a
luncheon at hermann goering's
apartment in berlin hermann goering was
then married to a very beautiful
aristocratic swedish lady who was very
ill
during the meal she had to lie down
she was not capable of even sitting at a
table the
hitler appeared at the end of
the meal because hitler was very careful
about
what it is that he thought he ought to
eat and he um
when asked held forth for
20 minutes giving
no chance to ask questions but then
shaft said i'm not here to ask him
questions i'm here to listen to what
he's got to say
that was the first meeting very
innocuous in its own way
it took place by the way across the
street from the square where we lived
since the uh gerring apartment was
within uh
eyesight of our terrace
kind of on east 64th street
berlin is very very much like new york
it's a marvelous
frothy nouveau reach town with
a lot of grim humor and um
uh a marvelously acid view of the world
now that it has come together again from
east and west berlin
the humor is even uh wilder
the i just heard the story of an uh west
berlin policeman
who was approached by what was obviously
an east berliner
who didn't know west berlin at all as
yet and the east berliner in his very
simple clothes said
how do i get to the zoo and the officer
said as
what
sir i think from your description of
your book
that the major thrust of it is
the conflict in the book is whether or
not he's guilty or not guilty
obviously the nuremberg trial from your
description found them not killed
let's assume for a moment that hitler
won the war
uh defeated russia defeated england
defeated america
and now they won the war would then
his crime be considered differently
let me just
of assisting in the economics
the the wherewithal for the uh
the german army and industry was
supplying them with economics to be able
to pay for
that type of thing germany lost the war
so you say well
it didn't work out too well if they had
won the war
and now his uh work
that he had done contributed to the war
as before when they lost the way he said
well he didn't contribute to it he was
just
doing business with him i'm not guilty
the germans agreed with you they locked
him up the moment that he was
freed by war crimes trials and they
arrested him five times
five different trials had to free him
each time i'll give you one of his
answers to give you an idea
of how pragmatic the man was
at one point his defense attorney was uh
asking him as he stood there tell me dr
you you were here to
heard to have a loud argument with adolf
hitler at the berghoff the
mountain retreat shortly before the war
what was that about and chad said i told
him that i would no longer supply
any federal funds for his
army and the the
attorney his attorney don't forget
trying to elicit an interesting and
positive answer said
well did you tell him why and shot said
oh
no he said if i had told him why i
wouldn't have any need of an attorney
like you
i'd have need of a preacher he knew
exactly what was happening
and the fact that he couldn't be stuck
i'll tell you one retribution though
when it was all over and he went back to
banking and i have a chapter called once
a bank were always a banker
indonesia asked him to help iran asked
him to help
iraq asked them to help egypt asked them
to help
all the emerging nations said shat will
straighten out our economy
the only people who wouldn't work with
him were any german bankers any french
bankers
any english bankers or american bankers
they simply
struck him out of their vocabulary
madame
why was he acquitted because the
indictment
was so narrow that based on that
he could not be and he could not be
convicted
it is like saying um
you're only guilty if you walk up
the second flight of stairs through the
back door
and then take the seat marked shacht
if he didn't do that that was it take my
word for it
the american prosecutor as you well know
since madame timmins is the widow of a
famous american
diplomat ambassador
the prosecutor was supreme court
associate justice
jackson he was no ninny
and he was thirsting to pin
shah more than anyone else because he
thought shah
was the worst that was jackson's fuel
thank you mr white um i'd like to read
your book and i know it's interesting
but
i just feel like he's evil right i would
shoot him i mean if you shoot a man
because he's
evil then you're doing what nazi germany
did over and over they simply pointed to
somebody and said you must be awful
you're jewish
let's get rid of you or worse
equally bad you must be awful your
father
had syphilis get rid of you or you must
be awful
you're deaf and dumb we can't use you in
germany
so these are i'm afraid it has to go
through the legal process doesn't it
i mean tell that to supreme court
justice jackson
part of germany it's a tiny tiny stretch
between germany and denmark in the north
west
they all spoke that marvellous language
called playdouch
and pladus is a language that is neither
english nor german
or danish
his grandfather was danish his father
like a lot of friesians emigrated to
america
in the 1870s in order to avoid prussian
army service
wasn't question of being afraid he
simply didn't want to be oppression and
subjugate it to them
came back to america but while he was in
america became a great great aficionado
fan of uh horace greeley the great
journalist
who said go west osha didn't go west he
went to upstate new york and went broke
so instead when he came back he was
going to name his son
horace grady shaq the grandmother an
aristocratic daniel danish lady said
nothing doing
he's going to have one decent name and
he became hyalmar a family name
why did hitler send him to dhaka
because shah finally
connected himself with the 20th of july
1904 attempt
44 attempt on hitler's life but they
couldn't pin it on him
so all he did is to get him out and and
and
isolate him and now i'm afraid i i i
can see a famous gentleman back there
who built my house
it it's okay it isn't leaking it's fine
that's frank deleon of telemark
in any case i'm very grateful to all of
you to listening to my stuff and
if i can sign any books for you let me
know thank you
what's up
because i have no business making up the
reader's mind
i'm just gonna say if you're dead left
it was
oh
i choose the people who are unlikely
um players with the devil
um people as tom said
who were successful
and didn't need this new rafter and who
joined them anyway who may i assign it
to
catherine with a c a-t-h-r-y
that way c-o-o k with an e-no
i just have to tell you i'm sorry
hello but you you didn't have to come
here in this
terrible weather do you already have the
ball i can listen to you
all now sir
thank you for coming now i must have you
i'm going to say one question
i want to buy a book but i haven't got
any money oh
i don't have money i mean enough for the
ball
but i want you to sign it i shall
instantly as soon
um no because most of the people are
interested in costuming
are not particularly obsessed with
uniforms no they're not you know i would
have to
take some ill and the others yeah
my name is
you know that's a north german name
actually yeah
and they worked with uh
yes your mother chose my true self how
wonderful
how wonderful and you remember the name
run
brand new yes that was here in this
country yes
my mother had a business in this country
uh
between 19 i don't know 42 and then
until the 50s and and i always thought
you had just stepped into it
no no i never joined her oh really
but um
thank you
i never know if one says the right thing
but
hello hello my gosh we have really got
you over here in this
crime
it's actually a treat
it's matthew with one tea or two t's
yeah
james and matthews who are well
irreplaceable
thank you so nice to come by thank you
thank you hello
hello there's a lady who said that you
have built her house
yes and and she said doesn't leave
there it is yes
and signed it up here so they'll know
who the sign was i just said
father frank delene's plural
thank you very much yours appreciate it
thank you very much this is yours
i got the paper it's fine that's great
that's great
i'll sign anytime you want you can start
in spring though sure
yeah that's fine might as well do a
little business while we have a chance
right
sure oh it seems eminently fair
thank you sir thank you very much yours
have yourself a very careful trip okay
spring lake
why don't you put it here because is
that against the law
no no
what is
with